hello youtube this is the reuben report
i'm dave rubin this is michelle collins
this is michael ausiello that's Gloria
Bigelow and we got to get right to it
Barack Obama the president of the United
States he did something that as a sci-fi
guy I just cannot believe talking
sequester and he confused a Star Trek
reference with the star wars reference
let's watch the clip I know that this
has been some of the conventional wisdom
that's been floating around Washington
that somehow even though most people
agree that I'm being reasonable that
most people agree I'm presenting a fair
deal the fact that they don't take it
means that I should somehow you know do
a Jedi mind-meld with these folks and
convince them to do what's right yeah it
never gets easy I'd never get these
watching that clip a Jedi mind-meld
there's no such thing it's a Jedi mind
trick and a Vulcan mind meld Michelle I
know you are very upset about I actually
love it it's almost like the hummus
sampler of sci-fi like for someone like
me who really knows not that much about
it I feel like I would take a little
sampling I can see the hatred literally
shooting out of Michael's eyes and I ate
it I have no idea what you're even
talking I mean mine trick mind meld
mindless I thought why are you not a
sci-fi no I don't know I have no I
didn't even catch I still don't even
know what you're talking about oh he
sure wasn't an intentional thing like
you know my niece and nephew tell me
that mashups are all the craze right now
is it possible that's what he was doing
it I have never heard a young person
sound older than the way we can
my niece and nephew with the mash said
they're backwards hats and all that
stuff it was a side fact i'm gonna go
with that i agree with you i was my
sci-fi mashup what wasn't there like a
moment in that where he's sort of
stammering through it as if he knew that
the mistake was coming and we've all
done this when you're talking and the
next thing you know you make a mistake
but there's just nothing like we gotta
give him a break sometime like so he you
know so he mixed him up a Vulcan
mind-meld order nice a Jedi mind-meld
yeah it sounds a little bit vaudevillian
like I like the sound of that I think
it's catchy and I think if someone were
smart they'd catch on to it that's
something and make a thing out of it
yeah yeah let's do that they took the
focus away from the sequester so again
maybe this was intentional right he knew
the reaction it was gonna get and that's
actually what I think is most
interesting about this because nobody
knew what the sequester was you know the
pundits new and all then we speak with
you how do you smooth again that's file
anyone crew okay that's gonna go over
they can edit that 99 5 55 years old
come on remember this if anyone over my
basic where nobody talked about Michelle
take it away can you explain that oh I'd
really rather not we have to explain it
you know it's like sequester natori it
doesn't make any sense I've done no
preparation for this you don't I do
another thing it's totally fine alright
so people don't know what the sequester
is but then this type of thing happens
and it trends on Twitter everyone goes
completely bonkers have we reached a
point in like the discussion in America
where the little errors and the the
sci-fi references are more important
than what's actually going on absolutely
I mean I think it's always I mean just
the question aren't the Pope's being so
close like isn't there a sequester
happening there too are those guys be in
sequestration's efficiently but that's
the problem is they're not being
successful enough that George panasonic
westering now to to like come to some
kind of decision well they're supposed
to we be allowed to molest X amount of
kids or something they're trying to come
up with the number that they're all
comfortable in yeah a lot of them want
it to be a lot higher so you sequester
than it is Michael what do you think
about that you're you're a big tweeter
and a Twitter personality what do you
think of these things that like you know
they get their own life well after
hearing what the sequester was all about
I found the whole Star Wars versus Star
tracting much more interesting yeah like
that is that's a that's a topic that I
can really get into ya dig deep into the
sequester thing I don't care does it's
like Ellen's vs The Beatles a little bit
like that big a little bit so letting
around also i just like to watch nerds
fight yeah it's fun the new a comic-con
and watch them get online it's like no I
was here no I was here now this seats
mine that's funny yeah now after all
this do you all know the difference
between a Jedi mind trick Oh God we're
gonna be kind of okay fine I still
nothing is no idea if I still take it
away stalking but if I and I could be
wrong I will be uh the Jedi mind trick
is when you use reminds like lift things
or like to manipulate someone's thought
ah ok hello relax i need help and then
the Vulcan mind trick my is my mouth
you're pulling it over this when you do
this with the neck from like spaceballs
that's what I thought that was well that
I like did this event you faint equity
well that's all from Star Trek man Julie
what's up that's just like a Vulcan
mandapam did the Vulcan pinch I don't
know what uh one of my mother's I'm
sorry alright well clearly we didn't
resolve anything we're gonna move on but
we're gonna keep it with politics uh
this this bush guy this George Bush
remember he was the president and now
his brother has jumped in Jeb Bush who
was the governor of Florida he may run
for president and he told matt lauer on
the today show so let's take a look at
the clip got that you're talking about
it sounds like you are gearing up for a
run those are the kinds of things people
do when they're increasing their public
profile are you going to run in 2016
this that's way off into the future I
have a voice I want to share my beliefs
about how the conservative movement and
the Republican Party can regain its
footing because we've lost our way but
you clearly have not ruled out you will
not definitively rule out a run for
president in the year 2016 I won't but
i'm not going to declare today either
man alright so there you have it we may
have
other bush you know we had one bush for
four years then we had one for eight
years we've had the Clinton we may have
another Clinton two people remember that
that's why we left England a couple
hundred years ago to like avoid
monarchies and families that just run
everything Gloria what do you think he's
running I mean it's very clear sitting
and looking at him with those glasses on
its face he is running for president
yeah he it's very clear that that's
what's happening right now do we need
another bush do you think that maybe he
could clean up the mess of the first
bush no one can clean up the messes of
the bushes it's just a gentle removal
girl can completely clean up there guys
it's the web we can say whatever she
just threw a softball are you really
David thank you hace LOL why aren't we
allowed a certain grace period after one
election before we start in on another
one apparently not my xanax prescription
has already run out from the last from
the last election do I have to refill it
now already yeah as I gear up for this
one I can't take it i need i need at
least six months yeah before we get too
deep into this a new election yeah
quarters daily laws and everything all
ready for next year in a break he's
running and he has a very good chance
really we think it was a good trip i do
i'm sorry i think that it's florida
number one and he's loved in florida he
also i mean he's going to grab a rubio
and they're gonna ride that horse that's
what's happening reboots going to drink
a lot of water and he's going to be
ready to run for vice president what do
you guys think of this idea that we we
pick these families like the bushes and
the Clintons and we just go time after
time it's like this endless brand like
we like them like we like you know
coca-cola like oh you know it so that's
always what you get but like isn't that
creating just this class that runs the
show give me something serious here I
there's just no way I can she was a
roomie well I ready to the vending
machine um you know I mean you're I
think people are like comfortable things
that they know and you know even with
the bushes look you know I'm a Democrat
but even I have like a very small soft
spot for George W because he was like an
adorable little animal do you aim and
Jeb who and I'm a Florida native proud
to say it from born and raised in Miami
you know he was like are like own
adorable Frankenstein who ruined things
but it was like Oh Frankie right now the
Clinton brand is so much stronger than
the mush brand yeah dad I think it's no
contest this was going to be the race
right now I think it would be a
landslide clearly for Hillary she's the
most powerful woman in the country the
most well-liked woman after our first
lady and you know I think people are
still stunned by what bush did to this
country so i don't know if that's gonna
be the contest i honestly don't think
it's gonna be a strong one I hope that's
the contest like if it is a Jeb and
Hillary then we're golden but I just
feel like I I definitely feel like he's
gonna run I think he's gonna grab Rubio
and I think it's gonna be a tough race I
on it I mean I know what is this like
three years three and a half years out I
mean right now but you know it's never
too soon Michelle we have three years to
talk about this and for you to go I want
to talk about the bachelor thank God I
know that's happening for three years
for this economy to improve and I really
do feel like at the end of Obama's
second term that this economy some was
very different than it does now yeah I
think I unemployment's gonna be way down
i think i think the Democrats are gonna
be sort of on in a really good spot yeah
what do you think about the way they
brand all these people how like we said
it before we started that even jeb
Bush's glasses it was like you are gonna
be the smarter bush you know like what
do you think about this just machine
that builds these people that's politics
though I mean it's not just picking
somebody up off the street and they're
just gonna be the president of the
united states they have to be groomed to
do that yeah you know that's just what
it is and yet none of you were wearing
glasses here today have three pairs of
contact lenses yeah so I like extra are
we sure that Matt Lauer's glasses were
actually real and not a prop these real
lenses in there they may well that is
that's what I want to find out get to
the bottom those lasses I were when I
like audition for the price is right I
was like look I look like Drew
like the back row and we're not calling
it I mean auditioned for 42 another view
audition for the price is right to be
contestant you have to be interviewed
beforehand have you done it and did you
get close to getting on it I did you got
on no oh I know women have been like oh
god no no but I'm saying are you kidding
yeah see I was told to lie i know that
this is the kind of politician I like
Price is Right politics like everything
is I let it go God yeah for sure yeah um
I was told you have to lie about what
you do like if you say oh I'm an
entertainer they're like we've no
interest in you so my friend was like
I'm a teacher meanwhile she's like big
fake tits to be like no I'm kidding I
don't know wait la story is great moving
on any boiling-hot we're all [ __ ] in
word all right well speaking of politics
and presidents remember that Mitt Romney
fella that nobody really liked well his
nobody likes me tour continues months
after the election he went on Fox News
Sunday with chris matthews and he
brought his wife who makes him
apparently more human let's take a look
but it was not just the campaign's fault
I believe it was the media's fault as
well is that he was not giving being
given a fair shake that people weren't
allowed to really see him for who he was
all right what about the media I'm happy
blank the media the media because
clearly were so likable me in this fake
man uh what do you think like it's
months later guys and they're still like
like I never understand this idea of
like well they wouldn't let MIT me beam
it like wasn't he was supposed to run
the country so he couldn't run his own
campaign running for president you're
gonna have all those people running you
around MIT yeah I'm you just he just has
to stop it already I want them to go
away I desperately want them to just go
away have and they're still trying to
like that spotlight right well you know
toke it up my ABC will give them an
interview or whatever but after that
then what no no I go they've gotta go
grace as gracefully as you can at this
point just and the irony of them talking
her talking about fair and balanced
media and
getting the interviewed of fox news I
don't know I was lost on her or what but
I agree that I mean everybody blames the
media you know that's the first they're
the first targets but I actually felt
like the media was more promet very I
feel the same way I feel like they were
very generous with him and kept giving
him time and time again to get better at
what he was doing and he just never got
a better well you know the guy you know
he was hiding money in the Cayman
Islands the forty-seven percent thing
like all of this stuff met me admit that
was myth being MIT so when they let when
he was himself people were going I
really don't like this guy but but the
idea that he's not running his campaign
is the scary part to me like how are you
gonna run the content can chat if we
have on your camp and any of the guy in
men in black who like unzipped is human
student was a giant roach like I felt
like it was gonna be that moment where
he skin falls off and he's just yeah
some someone go back to the part where
he was a homeless man getting gas
remember that the photos were like
that's far more interesting to me than
watching him on fox news yeah out in the
wild like that remember that old photo
of him looking homeless it was like a
two or three to the three days after the
election it was that night I think yeah
pumping his own gas that's a random
casting and his hair was like the other
way for the first time are mine I
would've voted for him yeah I would have
voted for ya i cal'late to him the other
pump my gas looking home wasn't pumping
gas in it overnight that's not well I
guess we have consensus here then that
nobody's gonna be on a sitcom Everybody
Loves MIT is that fair to say i think
that's yeah what about everybody hates
me everybody hates me which is similar
nah I already hate the cares about me I
really think that's what I didn't care
but it was me so I don't know yet too
busy to be a mother his mother to be on
that show I'm auditioning for that two
days with you guys what am i just being
a little kind about it I chrétien well
listen television might be dying for
that very reason that you're talking
right there a new study a rasmussen poll
is showing that more Americans are
officially as of basically this week
getting their news from the internet
rather than television this doesn't
surprise me as an addicted tweeter
that's pretty much where I get all my
info what about you guys are you guys
are you guys internet people are you
still old school
TV people where you were you getting
your name I am constantly Mission
Control which is laptop and TV so I it's
like for me choosing you know between
children like I I'm in it deep in it
yeah so I had to only have one which one
I mean if I had to obviously I would
choose the internet because it's a more
personal experience and you you know
it's more communicative in whatever but
you know Michael um I only get much I
get my news from matt lauer on the
tation when he's wearing his glasses if
he's not wearing his glasses i will go
to the internet completely untrustworthy
without glasses right ah mine my new
cell it is my twitter feed that's what
it is I mean I've I get all my news from
just refresh it that's my timeline
that's how I figure out what it's going
on in the world the days of me you know
going home and watching the nightly news
you know it's over it just doesn't have
to me lately it's like it's so catered
towards old people like if I happen to
watch the CBS nightly news it is it's
almost like um in full sign language
like they don't like every so it's crazy
every other story on the nightly news
always seems to be about the AARP and
what they're gonna do and that old
people are dying faster and the death
panels are coming so there really is
like a age divide what about you Gloria
where you get town crier yeah I just go
out and look for somebody to yelm the
street homeless person tell me what's
happening I uh I go to Facebook honestly
I'm the same way like I haven't much I I
took a break from the news for a little
while I was stressing me out I was head
MSNBC like unconstitutional Ike you've
got to stop it like you're becoming a
lunatic and I said to my mother if
something important happens let me know
and then she called me and she said Al
Roker [ __ ] himself and I said that's the
kind of fan thank you that was important
for letting me know that yes I figure
important things happen people will let
me know yeah well there were some other
numbers here that I thought were really
interesting six percent of the nation
that's six percent thinks that the
national media is trustworthy do you
guys think that can we trust the media
obviously we can trust us sitting here
right now do you trust I maybe I you
know I don't just that's
justic by default don't trust the media
because it's you know it's to say you
trust the Metis you know it's you seem
uneducated to say that you should always
have a unhealthy distrust of the media i
have but i don't believe truck I don't
believe me i bet i bet i bet ninety-five
percent of the people polled there will
believe most of what comes from the
media not believing in statistics and
giving a made-up statistic to back your
stupid oh it's not made light I out in
the parking lot earlier i did a hawk an
actual pole that was quite an losses
there was like a real party downstairs
yeah are you guys surprised to know i'm
gonna guess not that four percent of
republicans so even less republicans
think the media is trustworthy ten
percent of democrats so that's that's
pretty good one out of ten democrats
likes the media glory is unimpressed no
I i I'm just I mean who isn't me
everybody's the median it every because
that's you have the benefit of like
Twitter and Facebook week we're all the
media now because we all were all
posting we're all like retweeting things
and taking little bits and pieces and
creating our own newsfeed it's called a
news feed literally yeah so it just
feels like if I'm on my couch um you
know ever since I moved to LA I'm like
panics about earthquakes and if I think
my couch is like actually on a fault
line like is it shakes all the time so
I'm constantly checking first thing I do
is go to Twitter and search earthquake I
do that probably three times a day you
know then follow on Twitter that gives
you real-time like I know that is like a
real-time earthquake okay that would you
not know if the earthquake was really
bad enough I prefer no but if you if
it's one of those things like you said
it's like oh did I just have gas or did
the earth move yeah you know the area
was a fart yeah things on Twitter yeah
the shadow building tapes what do you
what do you guys think about how we get
all our news cater to exactly what we
like you know what I mean if your left
wing you follow MSNBC and all the left
you know where and we're just endorsing
like our own stuff like reaching to the
choir it's very boutique now media is
very boutique like you go to your source
that gives you the kind of stuff that
you care about and that you're
interested in yes and who cares about
the rest of the world like if if you
shop at Target you're not gonna go to
Fred Spiegel like you know what I me
like you go to where you need to go
people
like their points challenged in any way
so that's why Republicans are watching
Fox and everybody else is watching
everything else and then why I listen to
Rush Limbaugh all day all day long Rush
Limbaugh all right let's move on to Wall
Street everyone's favorite Street am i
right oh my lord guess what their
salaries are going up and quite
substantially wall street bonuses I've
got numbers here people uh they rose
eight percent to 20 billion dollars this
is the same wall street of course that
we bailed out and continue to bail out
and you know they just keep getting
bigger and bigger but we keep giving
more money you guys have any idea what
the average wall street person makes per
year I saw your notes for the show and I
remember thinking that is astronomical
we have much higher than I thought yeah
three hundred and sixty-two thousand
dollars is the average salary on Wall
Street they're given themselves uh this
bump in the bonuses nice guy around by
the way I didn't even mean to do that
there themselves a bump and a bump in
the salary right and uh what what do we
do like a we is there anything we can do
to stop this instead of gonna say marry
them Dave that's a get married to them
I'll pretty much right are you dating a
Wall Street pants no I worked on Wall
Street um this is a posture last moment
clearly as a legal secretary for four
years and we were on Wall Street except
i would show up in like thrift store but
not like the cool rap song kind like
really ugly [ __ ] but can occur you can
say that guys look great this is young
there's no no I know that they have a
type and it's not me to them saying so
it's me maybe like this I don't know
what you're implying about my journal
liquid I haven't worn in like eight
years we do nothing what do we do we so
we just can't they just hold us hostage
I feel like we've been hearing about
this every year and they keep going up
they keep going up I don't think there
is anything we can do I think it were
powerless for whatever reason yeah i
mean i don't eat cake though interests a
minute literally is getting to that
point was this what occupy wall street
was fighting against yeah well i say
nothing they had no effect they knew
what the shower is one out of the park
yeah no we think that obama is sort of
on our side with this but this is all
still happening under his watch you know
it means so she wait should we
it's a Jedi mind-meld oh oh yeah that's
the my mouth that's the mind milk the
mind trick would have been like you
won't take your bonus oh but they have
been nice they went with the bonuses and
so there's nothing we can do we just got
to put our hands alone if I really know
what I've never got to go to sell it
I've never get really i don't think so
you know it's like five hundred dollars
and like ran to like TJ maxx and bought
50 pairs the capri pants I got a
starbucks card one time and I felt like
that was a bonus that's a very nice one
actually yeah yeah actually you know
right now if you go to Starbucks that
time they'll put five extra bucks on
your Starbucks card what that's a little
bonus for you guys out checking yeah if
you have a starbucks card we've got only
one more segment and they don't get get
on starbucks calm and get five bucks
McDonald's they're cutting the healthy
stuff the famous fruit & walnut salad a
bunch of their chicken selects and even
some of their angus things are gonna
disappear what do we do if McDonald's
can't keep us healthy people there's a
different that's that's no being debated
that's all but that's not know but it's
like a higher cut of meat Thomas you
know what I mean the salad is the
healthy part two pieces of lettuce does
not a salad make if you can't get your
cheap salad at McDonald's you're just
going down the route of on health it
shocks me that they wouldn't just keep
the apples on the menu for show because
they know they're gonna be criticized
yeah for the thousand calorie burgers
regardless of whether people are eating
it just put it up there and try to make
an effort show that you're trying yeah
even fake apples would be fine for them
just like a horse you did for pick one
up horse meat is in basically every
tonight I know battle yeah cuz I'm an
animal um yeah it's delicious have your
profit affords me a good idea fact i
justjust that ikea the other day I shall
off me well I saw you know people love
that stuff that I here and there were a
ton of people feeding their kids and
it's like here they're being sued or
something for horsemeat you guys just
chowing down on the horse meat it's just
we just love is that just how it is
Americans we just love kind of the
crap we just love this crappy stuff well
they clearly don't trust the media
that's that's part of the ninety-four
percent that don't trust the media more
that's telling them to eat healthier
know that meaty that's telling that the
meatballs are made of horse meat yeah
I'm by it oh they don't even buy that
they don't even buy that they're like
media they're tricking us but um
McDonnell's I boycotted McDonald's I
have been going for several years now
and this is why and I feel like I'm
gonna get it out yes it's something I've
been keeping in for a while the only
thing I ever get a McDonald's is a diet
coke and an ice cream cone have you ever
waited 20 minutes on a drive-thru line
only to get up there for them to tell
you that the ice cream machine is broken
no that's terrible it's happened to me
for five times four or five toilet and
there's nothing you can do they need to
put a sign wait when you get to the
drive-through no ice cream today i have
to say i actually have stopped going to
mcdonalds dave despite what used to
dread I stopped doing it because it
actually has like the Passover effect on
me where it just stops me up and I know
what I'm talking about are there any
you're jewish yeah you know where your
house over again it is also like
physically stopped up you can't poop Oh
what I'm saying to you is it had more so
than any other garbage that you can eat
it like it's literally you're putting
like styrofoam I look like either a
boycott McDonald's like it was Noble
yeah I mean like you guys know I mean
over i scryed appreciate that you said
like you boycotted McDonough's and I
thought oh god what did they did apart I
like what is it what is it it was like
ice cream it was I see if you know what
here we've are they partners ice cream
played in my life you would understand I
respect that you are the way you are
just one part what about the hugs the
Rosa Parks at McDonald's what about via
the blizzard the Dairy Queen Blizzard
they mix the candy in there for you I'll
do the Dairy Queen ice cream cone um but
not the blizzard well you just like soft
serve I do yeah yeah yeah all right on
that note people I'm gonna let you guys
pimp yourselves out cuz i find the
guests can pimp themselves out in a way
that I I cannot Michelle I'm very little
to tell you I'm you can follow me on
twitter at mish call Michael take it
away I run tvline.com if you are a fan
of television
it's one-stop shopping everything you
could possibly imagine bachelor lot size
10 weeks tvline.com please no Gloria
Bigelow you can find me on Twitter and
Gloria Bigelow and i'll also be
performing in detroit go saturday at the
detroit comedy festival buddy passim
yeah there you go all right what we did
a little of everything we did some
politics some mcdonalds I feel like we
all sort of got a little brighter and
also a little Dumber this week when
really that's what it's all about I
thank you guys for watching and we'll
see you next week bonobos calm is the
official outfitter of the Ruben report
enter code Ruben report for twenty
percent off your next purchase